hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i am playing the
first hour of the guardians of the
galaxy game from square enix very big
thanks to square for giving me a code
that's how i'm able to play the first
hour of the game for you guys today
early i can also play a second hour
without breaking the embargo i think
depending on the length of the chapters
um so if you guys want to see more let
me know and i also wanted to say before
we jump into the gameplay which will be
obviously the bulk of this video just
like full gameplay um if you have any
questions about the game i can answer
them next week so um even things are
like later my overall impressions so any
questions you have about it leave them
below and i will be able to uh
at the same time reviews go out i'll be
able to give you my impressions so
let's jump into it um yeah very big
thanks to square for providing me
with a code so that we could check it
out
and i do
really want to make sure
that we do this first okay so i want to
note this um because a few games have
done this this game does come with the
option to turn licensed audio off which
is what i've just done um it's streamer
safe as it says this option removes all
copyrighted musical contents and
replaces it with alternatives um it's a
good option for players that wish to
stream their playthroughs publicly
without having to worry about copyright
infringement issues and i am going to
play it this way because naturally i am
broadcasting this and i don't want
youtube to get mad at me
however
from what i can tell
they did send me a list this game has a
really good soundtrack and
you do lose things in my opinion
when you replace the built-in soundtrack
of all these classic awesome songs
with
gameplay safe versions so note that when
you play it you'll probably be getting
songs you know and love whereas when
you're watching me play right now you
are probably not going to see those
unfortunately
um so that is all good
uh we'll have subtitles on for everybody
yeah that seems good and
accessibility i
[Music]
don't need any of this
oh all i win quicktime events is an
interesting one a lot of people hate
qt's
i might be okay um my main accessibility
need is that i can't button mash but it
doesn't look like there's going to be
too much of that so
let's jump into it
i've been very curious about this game
um
i didn't love the way that it looked in
gameplay but i couldn't really put my
finger on why
um i was gonna play it no matter what
very you know interested to see how i
feel about it
getting my hands on it now
yeah i kind of don't know what to expect
so
accept
accept
[Music]
that's cool with me
sounds good
okay
new game
and we'll just go with this is probably
the normal the default
oh wow there's a lot of options which is
great
huddle auto win
oh interesting
that's cool maybe there's like um
the option for the entire group to
vote on things like um
oh my god i'm forgetting the name of the
game
about rpg they're making boulder's gate
now larian
blanked on it okay none of this is gonna
mean anything to me i assume there's a
tutorial let's go
[Music]
[Music]
this is probably our first licensed song
that i'm not getting
it's a very interesting
choice for
gameplay introduction
[Music]
also this game's not first person is it
star lord
star-lord
who's the guy with the scary eyes
he doesn't have a name he's one of the
space writers and he's not scary he's
cool
don't love that performance so far
but maybe he's really young she's a kid
this is endearing
for the environment looks really cool
nobody says far out anymore mom
ma
nobody says far out anymore
oh that was cute
maybe we should see if we could get
tickets to see them live really she's a
babe you got a milf out here you're like
i cannot look it but i was quite the
rocker when i was your age
your father and i would just lie on the
hood of my old chevy and listen to black
sabbath and you like black sabbath
like i said your mom's cooler than you
think
oh we'd look up at the stars and he'd
tell me all about the places he'd been
mom
how about some cake huh
yeah i'll be up in a sec
you said that 15 minutes ago
if you don't hurry i'm gonna eat that
whole cake myself no you wouldn't yes i
would you wouldn't i would hey watch the
hair
this is having the same that just made
me tear up
which is
i have problems
the exact same effect that um it's an
action figure the guardians of the
galaxy movie action hat on me
stab your foot i will
never mind yeah i'm not a fan of this
young peta but damn they're really going
for it
okay he's 13.
where does time go um
family stuff the family themes and
guardians
really gets me like since i moved away
from home to pursue my dream job
uh work at santa monica studio it you
know it's it's worth it but um
being far from family like gets me and
and his mum walking in and offering him
cake casually on his birthday made me go
i would never get that again and it
makes me sad and stupid sorry
the um miles morales did the same thing
whoa
cool hair dude oh you got punched in the
face
okay well i'm finding this intro a lot
more interesting than i thought oh man
traveling through space must be amazing
yeah only we'd find out you know what
i'm saying you gotta yeah you're gonna
have to get bezos on that one mate
because you
definitely not going to space can't wait
to play this
super meg 3 10 take down tips
don't miss double toads ninja combo 3
true batter speed bots and baseball blub
i wonder if this game will do the same
thing the family stuff man it makes me
sad
it's stupid
it could be buddy it could
it's pretty be that all that destruction
started from one little mistake
three natural ones in a row last game
some barn i turned out to be
you play the guitar
need to build up my calluses
as someone who just recently started
learning to play guitar big same dude
cool guy
i can't believe i caught this that made
in show is awesome
yeah i'm not a huge fan of of the
performance of this
young quill right now but obviously
that's not gonna stay pull the stickers
off and put them in the right spot
fingers are still crap from trying to
bookmark pages i know it's not happening
also yeah if it wasn't obvious um tired
of dying everywhere probably is
uh i am playing on ps5
the movie was okay
the soundtrack really kicked but that
tron
it's funny
oh what's this one more thing i haven't
looked at
keep hitting those dingers george and
he'll make it in the walls nice nice
nice
cool
i'm into this intro i like i like this i
think it's it wasn't at all what i
expected it's
holy cute drax
you gotta stop doing this man it's
weird
we were approaching the quarantine zone
how long was i out for
and
15
eight ticks
that's
very specific
the betrayer is ready to begin our
mission she has requested your presence
in the cockpit
gamora's honor all right abs
she's the spawn of my sworn enemy a
murderous and a traitor i do not trust
her we'll try we're supposed to be a
team thanks kratos
so far i like this more than i expected
to i was expecting to jump in and have
a bunch of menus thrown at me or
something um
i don't know i don't know really
where i got that from but
more of a story focus than i was
expecting in any case
also the haptic feedback so far is
pretty cool and i don't even have the
day one patch which uh they said
improves haptic feedback so
it's pretty neat
definitely some great work on the
it ain't just a junkyard the quarantine
zones the biggest pile of galactic war
debris in the known universe just think
of all the tech we can find ah there you
are quill tell groot to stop worrying
about getting
arrested i'm not over confident i'm just
the right level of confident
if you had no idea who guardians were i
still feel like this would be awesome
arrested for what
like maybe even cooler
our ship just
accidentally slipped into the quarantine
zone oops our navigation malfunctioned
oops
how would we accidentally cross into the
nova corps force field
details
groot looks a little bit janky i'm gonna
be honest it can't be easy to model a
walking tree
but uh he doesn't look great
about gamora
and let's not wait peter quill i am
readying my body for battle uh
you know we're supposed to capture this
monster right not kill it of course
but i suspect it will not go down
without a fight lip syncs also very
often ain't gonna buy damaged goods i
will aim to preserve the integrity of
the beast as best i can good
very detailed environment this is cool
what is this it's gonna be a
can i just shuttle myself out of here
the engine parts from at least five
different black markets
nice
that looks cool whatever it is
this moment of quiet reminds me of the
legendary siege of sec not seven oh not
again it is said what is it dude
take five
we gotta talk about that gamora thing
she is waiting for you in the cockpit
are you gonna be okay you two are gonna
be alone on the ship for a while
rest assured peter quill i will keep a
watchful eye on thwart any attempted
treachery
or
you could try trusting her
you are naive peter quill
she is a mistress of deceit
it's a cool title
i'd be all right with somebody calling
me a mistress of deceit
this is pretty really needs to get these
plants under control i disagree
yep i use these for smuggling hopefully
i won't ever have to smuggle myself in
there
that's foreshadowing
[Laughter]
that's gonna happen
interesting that they choose to have the
streaming mode on thing at the top at
all times
i wonder if
you remember that dealer who asked about
the emitters after you left
he leans over me and he says uh what
what do you need these for then
the dialogue seems pretty good so far um
if it's either so that people know that
they're not getting the authentic music
or so the streamers don't forget i
suppose it could be for both
this is neat
oh
cool bathroom
not so sure about tooth cleaning tablets
manual brushing is where it's at
oh
wow cool
okay um
so drax excited to meet our buyer after
we catch the monster gamora up here
peter in the cockpit they said hey
that's my chair
oh
then why aren't you in it
i was uh
strategizing
it's one thing to get into the zone but
we still got to catch that monster
right
so did i miss anything
other than a ton of suspicious glares
from drax not really
now if you're done
strategizing feel free to grab your seat
we're almost ready to go
she's like
she's like raided
he's a cyborg
remember metal gear rising revengeance
underrated god i love platinum games
here we go huge fan
all right
rocket groot drax get in here we're
going in
we still have a few ticks before the
next time window actually
the next one
nova core security guard resets every
rotation we want to be in and out before
our code expires or we'll get stranded
wait for the next reset we'll get a full
rotation to do this nice
oh why is the nova net still up i
thought we were going in
it appears the assassin's contacts are
as untrustworthy as the betrayer herself
oh please don't tell me gamora's
backdoor coats are bust we nearly went
broke getting them
relax rocket we still got a few ticks
before the next time window
the network just reset
you can enter the sequence peter
zero four five one
that's it it's a weird way to say that
suspicious these security measures are
too simplistic for nova core
seriously it's not that simple the code
only works on this date that's kind of
cool i didn't expect that i get it
gamora's codes are more like an
encryption key in some stairs
it looks very cool
no doubt there and
[Music]
we're in incredible
people realize there was so much stuff
left after the war it's a very slow
start i mean they've been playing for
like 15 minutes or so but especially
with thanos i don't mind that
it's not my name we're all harmless now
i mean novacore had 12 years to get rid
of the heavy-duty explosives right
that's why i like you quilt you're so
pure
oh
the wonderful and terrible things i
could do with all this
stay focused we did not come here to
scavenge why not the milanos weapon
systems could use an overall plus
there's good money in it the beast that
we seek is far more valuable to the
monster queen of second island than any
illegally acquired salvage
whoa
place is really shifty
clearly i just like flowery looking [ __ ]
though
let's be real
fred
for a knight
and you'll see the monster soon as we
place rockets monster summoning thingies
vlark yeah
group
soda team rockets up first
i still do not understand why i must
remain on board with the assassin oh
because you're part of green team
assigned me to the team before you named
it my skin is not green
steel
teal
what
i mean it literally is he's right his
skin is teal i don't feel like that's
that's strange
thumpers on both sides two sides two
teams and two clips
that's our cue let's go group
don't worry once the thumpers are placed
we'll meet the middle and we'll capture
the monster
together
very well
okay gameplay time
they could do some really creative stuff
with this
okay
did you just put checked it in quotes
what no that's the purpose of it though
like does scanning these things actually
do anything it seems like i should okay
pick up items
otherwise this is gonna lead me to my
objective everybody keep an eye out for
any good scrap or components
i know the monster is the first priority
i'm just saying if you see anything good
along the way
i'm thinking that big cylinder thing is
our rendezvous yeah that's the mining
rig so weird seeing it all clustered
together like this
bits and pieces of a war that span the
entire galaxy held together by
pink goo
nano resin of course whatever i'm just
saying it's a lot to take in
ecliptic railing my bud
that's uh
an interesting way to deliver
exposition is to
the player i
still had control
but they just attached me to the railing
interesting
whoa look yellow and blue i feel like i
should be floating here like i should
come on dude all right i'm all right
with that died on that [ __ ] killjoy
why'd he even bring us here if the place
is so sacred
i can name at least a dozen planets with
monsters so why here
broke rocket we need a big break aren't
you tired of eating yarrow root it's so
mealy listen this is a restriction
oh
okay so they do have double taps which
is uh
maybe they do not have a
accessibility options for that
or button mashes is what i mean sorry
i'll look through the menu again in a
bit um
uh you didn't actually tell me how to
crouch am i supposed to just walk
through i am i told you we'll say i'm
not very impressed with the lighting i
like this this is fun i don't tend to
care too much about that kind of thing
just like when we started this but it
does look pretty flat
i do not hate everybody i tolerate quilt
well's a swell gun
the three of us have had some good times
remember the gig on draconius
careful on that thing quill just wanted
to see what would happen
turns out you just fall
it makes sense
oh that was cool it's safe to walk on
mostly
whoa
got your uncharted butt slides of course
of course
[Music]
you sure ah there we go pass this way
come on i saw it
why did it do that were you trying to
make me look to something
you think we could find pieces of the
try on shard in here
seem like a strange choice
that's it
yeah not not super impressed with this
graphically there's definitely a lot of
detail it's really the lighting that i
think i'm not loving but
in my head that means it's gonna be a
big game
if there's there's classic the lighting
isn't
you know
expand sparkly i tend to be like oh they
probably have a bunch of environments
which um i i prefer that in the
trade-off i think you know video games
are
limited
and lighting is
very expensive by expensive i mean like
not literally expensive but also that it
takes away from other things you can put
in a game watch your step guys this junk
isn't as stable as we think i'm gonna
shoot these take that brutal stuff okay
nice
when in doubt shoot the american way my
dude
america
yeah
nice bladder hey 50 unit says i can
clear more of these suckers than you as
if
all right
what the rocket did you do that the
scoreboard you like it that's cool your
advisor cover last time you couldn't
snooze
you hacked into my stuff considering how
many times i fixed the flarkin thing it
might as well be my stuff
okay
optimal thump replacing distance should
be just up ahead
i'm thinking right in front through the
giant hole where this ship's cockpit
used to be
well that's grim
uh
yeah try not to think
[Music]
i was waiting for something like that to
happen i should have been recording
oh
don't know that's cool for gameplay
quilt you okay down there yep
yeah i just uh
thought i saw a shortcut right go ahead
without me
i'll catch up
okay there's a cracked out novacore
missile bay just on the other side we'll
meet you interested to find out why i'm
picking these things up is it crafting
okay
crawling through creepy old ship
no big deal
i would also say right now i feel like
this may be a little bit too much chat
up but
oh oh that was shootable
um but it's not actually bothering me
yet and i assume it won't be that way
the whole way through the game because
that would be very difficult
now this brings back memories
[Music]
i shot something like you said i've got
a way forwards
it might be a little bit too much but
again i feel like that's just gonna be
in the intro i don't feel like they're
gonna
they don't have the capacity in theory
to keep up this much okay
oh aim and then yep
that's easy
it's pretty easy
i want to like if we get a bunch of
different enemy types or a lot of enemy
variety if maybe that'll
get it a bit more interesting
you just look like nipples
hey little nipple
fantastic
this is a very combo media game it makes
sense get devil may cry on me let's do
it
it's reminding me of the um the
activision deadpool game
or at least die with it not funny
all right where are we trying to go from
here
this way
i was attacked by strange creatures
got some real bad news for you sis them
critters you had me smuggle off crack
too did i pronounce it i don't know
you didn't tell me they bred like
snicker even mud hogs
i got a cargo bay full of the ugly
flockers and they grow up fast i can
hear them banging on the walls and
shrieking something fierce probably
hungry when i saw my fuel was leaking i
put two and two together and realized
that chewing up my fuel lines to make it
worse i gotta fly right through another
creep's blockade i ain't got no way to
hide them things so i'm thinking about
scuttling this old heap and taking my
shuttle to nowhere
expect a bill for any ship soon and we
can figure out our next hole i know
you're not good for it i know you're
good for it the opposite what can i say
scott happens okay well i hated all
those fake swear words that was not my
favorite
but
you do you riding
monster on i hope she's legit
like you could even tell if she had an
on his face
if we set up all these thumpers and no
monster shows we'll just need to salvage
what scrapper can hold back with us oh
my
oh
i thought it was going to lock me
it did not we actually have to walk on
this properly oh well there's the lock
yeah okay
are you kidding me you like your little
pink boots this makes this look extra
dainty
that double jump is awesome though very
fun i'm not gonna make this
but there's no real punishment for
falling so
okay just whatever him nicely he does it
for me all the time all right groot
let's see that's how you get your uh
companion abilities
i wonder how extensive that
gets gross more ship eaters ah they're
everywhere
all right back to business
well okay you i didn't see those i
didn't i forgot about that entire game
to be honest
do you want to grow us over there we're
going the right way just
root i found a hitch can you latch onto
it what does uh rocket do i wonder
if you see any blue and gold ships out
there you will let us know
we have seen many such ships he means
active ones
we haven't talked about what
bad idea those cops are all connected
through the stupid helmets if you see
cops you get my ship out of here even if
it means leaving us behind
i do like that you can opt into
responding i think that that's neat that
you can ignore it or you can if you want
to and then it has options
[Music]
i hate the fake swear words
i hate that it's driving me nuts that's
what's wrong oh my god
let's just find a solution the
solution's a new battery with a charge
okay
we're on what's left of a ship
full of ship things gotta be things that
power [ __ ] things around here right yeah
maybe you're gonna want to use your body
for this you find a replacement while i
finish scraping the fried wire found
something with a charge kind of looks
like a spacey car battery it does he's
right hey this thing isn't gonna zap me
right
the chance is
minuscule at best you'll be fine
here you go that'll do nicely just let
me tinker a bit i'll have to do some
tweaking once i see how much juice this
thing puts out so uh watch my back
the dialogue is constant which is like
impressive all things considered like
it's not easy to do
oh that's cool
groot the last flora colossus crude is a
vigorous defender able to withstand high
amounts of damage he focuses on crowd
control his basic ability and tangle
immobilizes enemies in a small area for
a short amount of time
i do think that these uh these different
abilities could end up being
pretty cool as combat gets a bit more
complicated
right now it feels like
easy for you to say
floaty
i don't know what what the term i'm
looking for is um
it feels simple i don't know
it's just fair for the very beginning of
a video game
see if we can use him again
i don't really think so
oh they break into smaller ones ooh
that's neat if you shoot in the air you
stay in the air that's cool i like that
that looked bad
uh what are the green things i wanted
damage multiplier okay yeah i think that
having played and video game before i
have concept of how that works
okay
we found a way out
i'm on it
brute's wondering if the reward's going
to be worth all the risk we're taking
for this job
me and groot are nearly unkillable but
what if the rest of you don't make it
out alive guys we deliver this monster
to lady hellbender we'll get bigger
payouts and jobs that don't suck a ship
for each one of us i mean a team only
needs one ship
some more spacious [ __ ] what no i love
my baby
man
that thing is ridiculous
i think it was a ship or a robot that's
a priest this looks like a robot to me
that ain't even the biggest one how do
you know all this because they were my
fellow experiments back on half world
most of my parts came from the
cybernetics hanger next to the door so
uh
i got a sneak peek at all the new kill
bots
i could see the parts come and go from
my uh
i feel like the story could end up
getting like they could get a bit deeper
than most of them are just scars now
anyways then maybe i would have expected
which would be cool
more like a real smart the fact that
you're going this way makes me want to
go this way
okay i'll have to check that out at some
point
all right
so drax
how come you're so in love with this
hellbender lady i do not love lady
elendra yeah should you be all like her
name is illogical you cannot bet hello
that's very easy to identify i
appreciate that that's good design it's
very very clear which ones groot will be
able to use in which you want
wait
is that
i don't know about that man
i'm doing pretty well so far
you less so
that said i can't see them all of course
there ain't any plants here
bro why you put your guns away
plants grow where they got food
here goes nothing
we're insane
and i got
there's some something strange going on
with the controls i don't know what
happened there
where are you finding them
you big jerk
i feel like i'll probably be okay
[Music]
speaks for itself oh well i but i i but
but i got them all man god damn it
you know what quill i think it's unfair
you got two guns i got one i think my
point could count double
that's cheating
all right bumper goes there quill
it's not going to piss off every critter
around right sorry quilt not taking
those well they don't seem like they're
a huge problem anyway i think we can
take said critics pretty well
i only flipped the switch on and off i'm
excited to see what rocket can do
flock bomb
rocket is a weapons expert who attacks
from a distance he focuses on damaging
multiple targets at a time his base
ability cluster flock bomb deals
moderate damage to everything in the
impact area
cool
that seemed to work pretty well um let's
do let's do a group
i wonder if they'll end up having like
um
uh
missions where you maybe have to choose
who you take and that will influence
like your combat
this round interesting
yeah at this point
i'm interested in the combat but i don't
love the way it feels um whereas you
know if i think about the games that i
played recently
uh
kina or
death loop um i feel like i immediately
love the combat in both of them whereas
this is like
just a bit more arcadey than i tend to
be into watch out worm things go
and yeah the amount of dialogue is is a
bit much but i also do feel
for you
i'll tone that down surely they'll turn
that down
this is cool as hell though that feels
awesome
i'm surprised by how good the recharge
is too
we can get rocket on there too
the fact that you can use them a lot
let's get
it good
i just maybe it's that i feel like i
should have more combat abilities than
just the the shooting shoots which
surely we will probably get at some
point right they did mention an upgrades
menu that i just haven't looked at yet
and all that
i'm gonna take a look at it we're gonna
take a look
let's go
okay
abilities
vantage point
yeah correct we immediately have
upgrades so let's let's do it
so this is stallone initiates a
prolonged burn of his jet boosts rising
to a tactically advantageous position to
give bodies and attack enemies
that seems neat
star-lord unleashes rapid okay this is
exactly what i was looking for it's just
like more
stuff
i have the hurricane stalin spirals up
into the air lobbing several grenades at
the enemies below that looks good
um
is there somebody else in here that i
can upgrade
let's go for rocket for now
we already have that rocket tosses a
grenade at an enemy oh they'll i guess
all only have four i wonder if maybe
that's the same for quill
yeah it might be or this this could
scroll obviously but it makes sense if
they only have four because they have to
mount them to the face buttons
rocket loves a grenade that releases
several darts on impact these shock and
deal lights stagger to each enemy for a
short duration enemies affected also
take
more stang at damage while under effect
and rocket tosses a grenade at an enemy
drawing others towards the initial
target's position i love that kind of
thing
um oh outfits did you say my my my
i wanted to look at groot
we have entangle
uproot is when groot causes roots to
shoot up from the ground dealing
moderate damage to enemies in range i
love that kind of that kind of attack
that um
the first dark side has had a really
cool i mean lots of games do it but
um
kingdoms amola has one of those two
um so it does moderate damage to enemies
in range and launching small to medium
enemies in the air mammoth grab grapples
a single large enemy in place dealing a
moderate
stagger and i want to see if i have any
outfits for oh hello there
warlord city lord
son lord
social lord
damn
which of these do i like the most
i reckon it's this one
fancy
fancy [ __ ] gamora
has deadly strike heavy damage to a
single enemy
shadow strike
oh that looks cool
that's neat
stag a wave strikes a single enemy
dealing moderate damage followed by a
wave of energy that deals moderate
stagger damage oh that's also very cool
she looks awesome
drax no wrong one
destroy drax hits a single enemy with a
powerful attack dealing light damage and
heavy stagger
drax charges forward dealing moderate
staggered wall enemies in a line
track shatters the ground dealing
moderate damage to one enemy and light
damage to all nearby enemies cool
all right
so now i can probably like
use the vantage point one
all right
good to know good to know
and now i look extra cool
of course it's secure
as secure as the broke down atari
shipwreck's ever gonna um that's you bud
that's you
i wonder if there'll be environmental
abilities for each of them as well if
they will all have environmental
abilities as well as combat abilities
like two separate menus
i really am more interested in this from
a game design perspective
than i am assuming that
regular players are interested in this
kind of stuff but i am like
the resin can hold a stupid warship
i'm telling you it's totally safe see
i'll even prove it huh look at this
but maybe the streaming mode does that
too i don't know i doubt it
nice swipe buddy handy to have a tree as
a friend
oh no
if you're in outer space where do you
fall to
how was there gravity for that i have
many questions
what does it mean
[Music]
you flock a piece of moldy driftwood you
could have died saving me
nah he pretty capable he large tree
sound of a chog come on cool he says
i'll meet us at the mining ship i don't
want to make him wait
does that mean that um
quill can't understand
rocket knocked an old shipwreck off
bounce and we lost brute what
[Music]
there's nothing to worry about whatever
right like you said where are you seeing
them damn you everything is
fine exactly we're all fine sure
fine oh he gets double now doesn't he
if that afterburner kicked on right now
we'd be toast let's hope it don't
because we have to find a way through
this thing
hmm
gets on the other side of that turbine
so we got to find a way through is it
here to jump on anything rocket can i
send you through that grab you if you
will either shut up or help me figure it
out i feel like maybe i send you through
that because i'm going to be honest
is what's going to happen here there's a
drone access tunnel over here
can you squeeze in there yes
i think he probably can rock it clean up
the mess rock it crawl into the mystery
hole see anything yeah emmanuel override
rocket
as close as possible to the original one
because of
maps and angles
great another turbine yeah that is how
these things are usually though
i'm confused about that
maybe it's that i need to hold it for
longer than i think
did you just pew pew
on let's get out of here
we're back on track the mining ship
ain't too far i think root's already
ahead of us maybe
hope he didn't get distracted oh boy
cool i love a i love a slighty dodgy
gameplay no not that that one
why
hmm
damn it rocket dammit rockets
okay
oh boy
yeah i assume i wasn't supposed to fall
there
we're seeing a lot of movements yeah
[Music]
oh i just didn't make it the first time
i had the right idea strange
okay okay okay okay
it's a lot of action
i really hope there's an option to hold
instead of um
mash but we'll see
[Music]
got it
no rush
it's nice and cozy in here oh so much
when you can't see in the dark
crap what my visor went supernova
is it broken overload it sounds like
maybe some kind of redis energy in here
ah come on
larkin tensor joint just
wiggles
okay so life supports boots back up
what's it look like out there
all right
huh
i don't know what that is
hmm
cool you okay
yeah yeah it's just
man
oh my
oh
hello
well
that's concerning
cool
did we see this in one of the gameplay
videos i think we might
i like it though i like the design
it's a swarm of old cleaner definitely a
swamp of all cleanup balls one hundred
percent
what else could it be
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
you okay buddy
[Music]
i feel like i would want to take it with
me but maybe that's just me
maybe that's just me sorry about the
shooting yeah i thought you were that
freaky thing we accidentally released we
saw
we saw some cleaner parts accidentally
at a distance
we're totally all right i just ran away
when it saws right quilt
yep just a freaky floating creature
nothing to worry about oh and speaking
of freaky creatures want to bet green
teams having trouble parking the ship i
think i'm done with uh bets for today
yeah you and me i think we tied let's
just get to the rendezvous point
uh nobody won it was just an excuse to
shoot stuff
hang on
maybe i did win then i'm not sure
i may have tied it was a cute thing to
have like a little bit of rivalry though
it's a cute idea
that voice actor
there you go it's gonna be a wild ride
you just kind of gotta say i'm groot a
lot
i'll try to find a side passage
nope
i found
look one this old beauty
a table
this is a vintage model t engineering
workbench they don't make them sturdy
like that no i'm excited for you buddy
come on let's see if this beauty still
works maybe i can fix up your gear hey
hand me that part
with rockets i'll use a workbench to
craft perks
ah okay cool
cut rock extract resources do you see
any components
for that
rapid reload and a gate cooldown period
due to element guns overheating
completely got rid of cooldown
that's neat wait i can do more than that
can i
yeah there's a way through if we can
clear out that crud
it's a cool way to do this menu too i
like it um okay so we have 900 right now
charge shot by pressing rt twice charges
sorry r2
charges a shot release to deliver a hit
then it flicks by staring fingers damage
tracked enemy drops from a profiting
moves away
firing rate doubled
tactical scan air glide
i like that because it sounds fun
oh the perfect dodge is probably what i
want though
okay cool
already glad to see
potential evolution
of the gameplay
oh
neat nailed it neat
that's cool rapid reload allows you to
cancel guns cooldown deal extra damage
yeah it's like it's like he has a wall
thanks for the upgrade active relic
perfectly safe right
i don't trust your definition of safe
doesn't seem so bad down there
it's a
hang back little
sec
uh you could have just jumped man he
would have been fine oh hello who was
this
oh mine
hello big boy
oh you really can just kick the crap out
of it well that's also another
development
[Music]
another one
cool
let me collect all my green things don't
mind me i love green
see you things whole place is old
equipment that does not narrow my search
yeah i'm not so sure i wanted me to go
there
we are pretty specific about what you
can jump on as well with the white
scratchy scratches
it is not a question of luck peter make
some noise
didn't seem like he was really screaming
because
give the active reload a shot
it's neat
you get to do it
indefinitely
oh you do okay that's actually pretty
stagger cool some enemies have a stagger
bar making them much more resistant to
damage their stagger bars always place
below their health bar feeling it
completely will momentarily [ __ ] them
okay
very secure of you
[Music]
cool
[Music]
nice
jax is a durable broiler able to take on
many enemies at once he specializes in
staggering enemies impervious to regular
attacks his basic ability to destroy
deals light damage and heavy stagger
i guess stagger is going to be a pretty
frequent thing then
i suppose so
so she does just a bunch of damage oh my
god she does a lot of damage
wow
deadliest woman in the galaxy gonorrhoea
is a skilled assassin who swiftly
eliminates targets she delivers quick
high damage attack so basically deadly
strike kills heavy damage to a single
enemy okay so you get her to take out
the big voice i suppose
i feel like it's an interesting balance
of abilities too
[Music]
i parked the milano near the last
thumper spot we'll head that way she can
reach certain out of reach touch my baby
let's see that fancy footwork gamora
yeah you can't do this
that is physically impossible
drax you can have that container behold
the might of a catastrone warrior
i'm assuming it's not going to give me
an animation every time just doing that
so that uh remember this moment please
retain the information
[Music]
rocket not now quilt
rocket perhaps he has located our
monster we don't even know what it looks
like
the intel was extremely vague
it was a pretty seamless way to swap
this
it's
destroyed our outpost we journeyed for
15 rotations to reach the healer every
night was harder than the next as
shalom's breathing worsened
we could find nothing medically wrong
with him the chitauri
assault had damaged his mind and he was
simply giving up after he'd let us
through so many battles we weren't about
to let him go out this way we found his
church aboard one of the converted
mining ships the line was long but the
excitement is palpable each time we
advance we could hear his screams of joy
at the front
of the crowd when it was our turn we
approached this gold skin miracle worker
i do not have the proper vocabulary to
describe him but it is the closest we
have ever been to divinity wow
the healer pressed his hands against
jim's forehead and whispered to him our
friend's eyes widened and he took a deep
breath for the first time since he fell
in battle oxo be praised he was healed
jelen has been distant on our return
trip we believe he's simply dealing with
his needless experience we hope he will
be himself once again soon
so hard to say right now
notes that are written around are not
terribly interesting
not that they're not interesting they
don't feel very relevant um like who are
they teaching me about is it important
uh obviously i have to wait and see for
that kind of thing
but um
compared to
i don't know a lot of other games have
been playing recently i suppose they
feel less impactful but uh you know
we made it to an hour mining ships
before but i don't remember ever seeing
catapping starfighting i want to wait
for them to stop talking but i don't
know if they ever will invaders to raise
most of our a
so yes uh if you guys have any questions
uh please leave them in the comments and
i will do my best to answer a bunch of
them when the embargo for that is up and
i can give a bunch more detail after
having played more of the game for you
guys right now i will say i'm not blown
away by this
i'm actually very interested in it from
a design perspective and as a result of
that think that i will continue to play
it
um
because i feel like they've done some
unique things in terms of game design
but i'm thinking about that from the
perspective of someone who now works in
game development much more than i am
from the perspective of a player
so i am going to keep playing it for
sure in in interest of being like hmm
here's how they did all these kinds of
things with these party members and did
you guys have pets
yeah it's interesting um i'm not really
sure how i feel about it but
yeah as a player though um
i think it probably could get to a point
where combat's pretty fun if it gets
harder and those upgrades get more and
more significant and more customizable
so
currently like pretty much the same as i
went in maybe maybe i like it a little
bit more than i i did from the initial
gameplay impressions but i'm also not
blown away i'm you know meddling on it
overall but um we'd love to hear what
you guys think as well like i said let
me know if you have any questions huge
thanks to square for giving me early
access to the game so that i could show
it to you guys today
hey we'll see you guys next time